Good morning, John. I'm here today with
Michael Aranda.
Mike: Hello!
Hank: Introduce yourself.
M: My name is Michael Aranda.
H: I framed this shot poorly.
Today, Michael and I are going to be putting together the Millennium Falcon.
(musical fanfare)
Why are they making you do the people first?
The people seem like they're the most fun part.
You should save that for last.
I think this is Han's hair.
Somebody's legs.
Where are all the heads‽
Han Solo is complete!
The thing was not cheap by the way.
It took me a couple guesses
...to guess how much it cost.
They forgot to number this bag!
Thank goodness that he figured that out 'cause I would never have.
What the frick.
*Beeping sound.*
I figured it was going to make a noise.
What did you think of that, Lemon?
Don't like it! She doesn't like it!
We're on to pack 2!
(Evil laugh)
(music plays)
What is this?
I don't know.
All right pieces, like make Lego happen.
What are these?
What are all these?!
This this is fro- this is still from bag two!
M: Wasn't this bag one. Oh look! We're going to use it right now!
H: We are! Where do you put it?
M: I don't know, hold it.
While, you do the rest in the page 75... no tube. Where is the other book?
Hank: Dude, the tube will happen when the tube happens.
(music plays)
H: They're pastel! What do they taste like?
M: Like Reese's....pieces, but...harder.
H: Harder, yeah! I don't like them. I did this wrong!!!
We're installing the tube part which Michael was very excited about earlier.
M:Tubular!
H:Really? Yeah?
Perfectum!  Last page...
of the first book.
M:Careful. I dropped an egg in my cleavage.
(Hank laughs)
(music plays)
H: We're on to number five.
Show them the Millennium Falcon as it currently exists.
Ah, God, it's scary.
We put the feet on, we've got a blaster on the bottom.
H:Interior living space is done.
M:One of the blasters came apart.
H:Nooooo! Sh-
It's like every time you finish a bag, it like
... is from harder to easier to easier to easier to find pieces,
then you start a new bag and it's like, ARGHHH!
It's hard again! Cardigan! Madmartigan!! Tartigrade!
It's late.
So now going to continue our build.
(music plays)
It is now 2 o'clock in the morning. Michael is finished with his Mountain Dew.
The Millenium Falcon has another, uh, blaster on it.
It actually looks pretty much like the Millennium Falcon right now.  Bag number 6!
Careful! Couldn't do it, people!
Awww!
I don't know what's happening. Awwww!
(laughter)
(music plays)
Everyone, it's finished.
(Hank makes spaceship noises)
(music plays)
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.